the following content is provided under
a creative commons license
your support will help mit
opencourseware continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of mit courses
visit mit open courseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so this is the second part of the
class and this is the last
semester so i think i think you've
traveled a lot
you know
you see that many difficult issues i
think and i want to give you credit
actually for
throughout the semester for being so
open
honest and being able to engage into
difficult
uh issues and i and each time that you
guys are presenting you might
you might have remembered me nagging me
to
to get deeper into personal issues and
not just be abstract
and the reason is because i think you
make a much better case whatever you
want to argue
you can bring your own biography into it
and i think it overall i think it worked
in fact i myself
you know learned so much you know
throughout the semester from
listening to some of your own personal
discoveries about yourself culture
about issues of race language gender
sexuality
and and i give you lots of um credit for
that it's risky
and because before you came here you
know each other most of you right and
yet to be able to open yourself
to these difficult questions and to give
answers that were so thoughtful
and and so uh many of them actually i
didn't expect some of you to
literally come out in this class right
so
i thought that was very brave so i gave
you
my respect for that so i'm coming
and starting to hear yeah
okay maybe you've got things that you
feel
uh you want to take with you next step
so that you feel that others who come
after you this class might benefit from
anything that you want to share in terms
of your learning experience in this
class
and how you think you can reach those
gaps
that we've seen in terms of our society
our families
um so i wasn't here last thursday but i
i watched the
video before class and and they are too
like i was actually very impressed by
how
uh you guys brought up personal issues
so but there's a lot there to work on uh
some yeah yeah
for this class for this last uh
40 minutes or so
so i'm not sure if i fully understand
what i'm supposed to say but i'm going
to say what i was thinking um
so for me personally throughout this
class i think i realized i like explored
myself and like
my identity way more and i think i was
forced to ask questions about myself
that i hadn't
um and for me the main thing i realized
is like
how uncomfortable i am with being
multiracial like i enjoy being
multiracial but i didn't realize that
there's parts of me that like
don't necessarily fit together um and
how like i don't really see myself as
one certain race or whatever um and i
think you know the things that helped
with that were like you know our
personal essays um
and like the definitely the free writing
assignment
that one of the guest professors had us
do like and that got pretty deep
and like i was kind of like oh crap i
have to write at like 9 30 in the
morning when she first said that but
then like i really enjoyed it as it went
on
um and i think like maybe bringing out
more
multiracial like topics um next year
would be beneficial to people like me
who like
didn't even know that that was like a
problem within themselves
um and i think like also a really
interesting topic that we went over was
like
i think what do we call like faking no
passing passing
um and like how that's a privilege and
like
talking about like all the controversial
issues on that i don't think i really
also thought about that before this
class um so that was something i
benefited from yeah
okay so you you you uh said
faking sort of passing yeah and that
made me recommend that cynthia admit
back then
right that often when we think of
passing we think of it as a
something which is uh negative but i
have to tell you that point which i
remember very well that was very
important that
that international fashion should not be
as expected and there's a way that one
can think of
of passing as a normal survival strategy
in a way
so maybe it's a nice big way to think
about that you'll have to talk about
that but
you know again
again nothing can i have another one
sure of course you can go to brooklyn
um so i guess it's sort of hard uh i
think
it sort of takes a lot of reflecting
yeah i think about like all that we've
discussed
um but just on sort of a
quick note one of the things that uh
this class has sort of solidified for me
is the importance of
conversations and so
i think most of the learning that i've
done
in this class and other sort of seminar
based classes
sort of pales in comparison or what i
learned in my technical courses because
in comparison to the things that i
learned
in classes like this because
at the end of the day i think most of
the learning comes from those around you
your classmates this set of experiences
that they have
more so than you know what you learn in
these technical classes
there's a thing that says like five
years after you graduate you won't
remember
90 or whatever what you learned in
college
but i think what you do remember is sort
of these sort of conversations that boil
down to
personal experiences um and so i think
again there is challenge in this world
of sort of approaching people who
aren't really willing to have these
conversations
um but sort of changing yourself is the
first step
and i think if everyone sort of makes us
or has this realization
takes a step towards making this change
um
it's very idealistic but i think the
world would be a better place so
i think that's probably one thing that
i've gotten
oh man bouncing off of
what brooke said um
i think one way in which i would like to
see this class grow
is the integration of having some sort
of conversation
like open discussion inside a debate
with someone who
um does not come from a similar
theological not biological um
thank you ideological background as most
people in this class
um to try to see to sort of
gain practice in uh having a session
with someone who's a lot
different from you and developing a
common trust
and coming to see each other's
viewpoints in a way that would be
more informative than what
one could do among a set of like-minded
individuals
um let's see so one thing that i enjoyed
about this class
um i can distinctly remember one one
class that
literally blew my mind um i think i
turned to somebody was like oh my gosh
um and that was when we interrogated
what mit was as an institution and where
we sit
um in this field in this hierarchy of
social
you know the social hierarchy in the u.s
um
and i think when coming to mit i was
willing to give
the institution a free pass a lot
because i felt that i was getting
a lot from the experience but i think
now that i'm a senior and all the
seniors here grant our last day of
classes guys
now that i'm at this point where i can
think back on what mit has done for me
and what
and how it functions i think i'm better
poised to
um think more critically about
the institutions i choose to join in the
future for
post graduate education and after
um so i took this class as a challenge
to myself because at the beginning i
knew
about the prejudices and stereotypes
that i had been taught
and i wanted to get rid of them i mean i
think this class has helped a lot
with that just by hearing everyone
else's perspectives from the readings
from
looking at the world by taking a step
back
and like looking at things as they are
and not how we were specifically taught
that they are
um and i really appreciate that
i want to like from here on i want to
like move forward and try to figure out
how
like how to
be an ally from an asian american
perspective because
a lot of the times asian american
families
try to be the status quo like
my parents have always taught me to like
try to be
not explicitly but implicitly like try
to be as white as you can
um and i think that that was a really
difficult
lesson to go through and then come to a
place like mit which is so diverse and
which has so many different
backgrounds and to like come in thinking
there's a hierarchy where there isn't
and now going forward trying to break
that down
a lot of what i was thinking about
during this class
for me personally was comparing and
contrasting because i come from
uh very i'm from zimbabwe so there's not
a lot of diversity and
this was an entirely new experience to
me so a lot of what i was doing was
comparing
my past my history my experiences with
you guys experiences and everything
around me and thinking about
for instance in the readings how they
analyze different situations the
situation in america
the situation in haiti and thinking
about where these things are connected
how they're different
what could have been done what should be
done and i think
i i really thought about issues like
this before this class and now i'm
starting to think about it more
especially in education i'm really
interested in education
and how we can help teach
people in the future how to use this
skills that they learn how to think
about certain things how to approach
certain problems in a way that
challenges them and also challenges the
status quo and
challenges the hierarchies that are set
up so personally i think that
this class definitely helped me think a
lot more
and i hope that in future it will help a
lot more people think about
their actions think about what they're
saying think about what they're doing
and think about how they can help and
how they can engage
their communities for instance i
remember when we were talking about
how we we came to mit we might graduate
and then
how what are we going to do when we go
back to the communities where we come
from
what how are we gonna how do we plan to
affect those communities
do we go back as experts or do we go
back as one of them do we try to fit in
like questions like that are definitely
things that
we should think about and i think are
very important
yeah i think the biggest thing for me
was like
learning about what we were learning but
then thinking back to
how i grew up in like a really white
area and i was always taught
like there's one correct way to speak
there is like
one correct way to teach kids
and like thinking back now with like all
this information on how damaging that
really is
and how it it's not really about the
language and it's not really about how
we speak it's more about marginalizing
groups that might speak that way and
it's like
just thinking about how like my entire
school system
was based on like what they thought was
correct and what was
telling us what we should think is
correct and i think
coming out of this
hopefully we can try to change some of
that
in in the school systems because it can
really affect
uh how kids view the world as they grow
up
um i think one thing i gained from this
class is kind of
uh i guess verification of the idea
that listening is like very important
and it's
it's kind of various ways you could
think about it like just in the context
of this class whether it's like
listening to like other people share
their experiences and like kind of
really take it in and understanding like
how they fit
in within like whatever social hierarchy
or whatever
kind of issue we're discussing and
seeing how it's kind of played a role in
their lives and kind of seeing how you
could apply it to
either better someone else's life like
improve your own
um kind of interaction with the world in
some way or whether it's listening in
terms of
like language you've talked a lot about
language and like um
kind of how certain modes of speaking
are somewhat marginalized so
ensuring that like as you go forward you
like really listen to people regardless
of how they present their ideas or
present their thoughts
or whether it's like listening as far as
like engaging people who have opposing
opinions as you
like really understanding that in order
to strengthen your own positions and
really understand why it is that you
think the way it is
you have to be able to listen to people
who kind of think in a different way
than you
so yeah i've just seen a lot of uh kind
of different things in this class that
speaks of importance of
listening um i think
what this classes made me call into
question a lot is
my like lack of analysis of my
racial background um like because i'm
japanese-american it's not really
something that like i'm forced to
address all the time because
no one's really calling that much
attention to it because
neither one of those groups is like
really that
attacked in like modern society as like
for like being a racial group and like
something i didn't really even think
about it's like
my mom is an immigrant i didn't really
address that ever because
no one was calling to question her
immigration here
um and that also leads to a lot like
relating to
how um like other the opinions of
other people and especially like my very
conservative extended family
and how their opinions about certain
things such as immigration
are reliant on people being of certain
races and being from certain places
because it just
isn't something that they've ever seen
negatively
about my family but like it is something
that's a core part of
why my family exists um
so i think things like that um like make
having people address their like
own identities and their own backgrounds
and how that's affected how they see
everything else in their interactions
with other people i think is a really
great part of
this course um
i'm having trouble distilling everything
down but i guess one big takeaway from
this class was that
accepting that there's no one right way
to exist as like a human across like
generationally race in class and things
like that
and that was a realization that i think
i came
to in this class um and it all goes back
to like the importance of interrogating
your beliefs and why you think
the ways that you do and it's really
eye-opening and i think it's really
important but you have to open yourself
up to that um and it takes like
a certain level of vulnerability like i
wasn't expecting to come out in this
class
at all um but i did because this was a
place where i like felt safe and it was
like
really surprising that i felt so safe in
this in this environment
um and i think that's something that we
need to recreate
um elsewhere another thing that i would
like to take
for this class like in the future is
like there are people who aren't seniors
taking this class so like what what do
you do now
what classes do you take next or like
what actions can you take
because of like what you've learned in
the class and i think something that
maybe that can happen in this class is
thinking about concrete ways to actually
do stuff because we have professor
chomsky in here on tuesday and he said
almost anything is the answer to like
what do we do so
maybe having some sort of initiative
like coming out of this class is to like
make change maybe just hitting my teeth
or just like awesome
um so kind of piggybacking off of what
chris said i think
the most meaningful conversations and
talks that we've had
for me where when we
talked to professors people all over
cambridge who were
using their own backgrounds their own
fields of study and they're making
tangible changes as chris is saying
so for example when we watch the like
the virtual
reality kind of simulation in terms of
the
israeli-palestinian conflict
and i feel like those conversations and
the fact that i
have the privilege of taking this class
in my last semester has really
kind of driven me to really
to take action outside of mit
and hopefully in the future back at mit
and
to really take that with me in my
specific field so
medicine and and how these um
various identities can really um affect
people's kind of healthcare and and
um and that's that's life or death
and it um and so i feel like that that
has really
been eye-opening for me and that's kind
of driven me to
to action yeah i think for me
um from this class has made me more
aware
of how many things i know um for example
what i didn't know about the haitian
revolution that occurred
and i didn't really question it during
the time
um but it's all the things that we are
taught just because a lot of the
history that we learned or taught from
like a very like western expert
perspective so i feel like it's very
important
that this class teaches that there's
always many ways to
view certain things and there's certain
many things that aren't necessarily not
just because um
i guess society just doesn't want us to
know about these things
so then we go learning
i think similar to what her mom was
saying i think
this class has really brought up the
idea of taking action
um and a lot of our readings like
passivity was
just like there all the time the people
i remember and
the needs of serena
the were was just like oh that's really
strange but i guess that's just the way
things are
so he was like he noticed that things
were wrong but he didn't do anything
with them
so i think just trying to take action
and many of you mentioned like
interrogating yourself is an important
way to do it and i really liked the
first assignment which was a linguistic
autobiography and i felt
that just thinking of my whole life in
terms of
the languages i grew up reading writing
and how they were presented to me
was a really good way just to to look
into
my own self what i think would have been
would be better in future versions of
this class
would be maybe talking together in
smaller groups
i guess i think it's easier just to talk
about yourself um
and that will for some people are more
comfortable
i think the only time we got to do that
was last tuesday
we had um professor allen um here
and we worked in like groups of three
and that was really cool okay
thank you thank you i i think so what
sarah just did also
hearing my permanent side and also what
chris can
try together because this class i hope
will be offered
many many many many times again here uh
i hope and actually we're thinking of
next year
i might do it with uh foxaro so
from that perspective maybe you guys
could share with me
what you think will be done to implement
what you guys see in terms of
taking this knowledge and into action um
because throughout the semester i was
struggling with what kind of projects
uh do i assign because i often felt that
it would be so nice to do a project
that puts you guys in the world not just
writing an essay you know
and i try to see whether something could
come up spontaneously from you that you
could own and say well i would do this
uh so how would you advise me in the
next
cycle of this course to make that happen
you know to
to do projects maybe throughout the
semester or maybe later on or optional
projects that would
really turn knowledge into action okay
um so maybe something is like i still
think you should have the essays because
at least for me they were
pretty beneficial in exploring myself
yeah but maybe instead of having like
the essay revision
although i think like revising your
essay is important i think that could be
done
throughout your essay process instead
and maybe like putting in a project
where you have to create
like a policy or like a lesson plan or
like
something like that um and then present
that
um and maybe even have a plan of action
of who you would go to talk to
about this because i think like if you
just come up with a plan it can be
pretty like
you know philosophical or just like just
an idea and we'll never be done with it
but like what would be your next step
now you have an idea
how do you implement it um and then also
um something i forgot to mention before
what i thought was really useful about
this class was when we went to go
to the movies all together on a saturday
and at first i was like oh crap now i
have to like a lot a lot of time but i
actually
really enjoyed that and was hoping the
conversation would keep going
okay um so maybe having more things
outside the class
um because i think it's really hard to
explore all the things that you would
want to do
in an hour and a half right um so like
maybe having somewhere
like i don't know what types of places
you can go to but maybe going to a you
know industry school in boston together
and like seeing how it's taught there
and what you would change that's good to
hear actually because one thing that i'm
talking with with
fox with the herald is to see whether we
could change the format instead of
having an hour you have to have
once a week for three hours and in the
past
i tried that but because of the
schedules at mit it's been hard for
students to enroll for a few hour
classes
undergraduate and so we stepped away
from that but now we're picking up
whether we should
do that and then maybe three hours we
could
go someplace else yeah i think that
might be beneficial i know like
negotiation that sloan does it at like
thursday at like five or something like
that
so it's hard to schedule like a three
hour class during the day but if you do
it as a night section
okay okay okay okay thank you for saying
that okay so i'll report back to the fox
and we can see what
it was you know sarah and then champion
well it's related directly to what she
just said about the time
okay it's just like a short thing that
um having a class of five would be
difficult because there's a lot like
no athletes to participate um yeah
because they practice from five to seven
yeah
okay yeah there's another section at
seven i'm pretty sure from
seven to ten yeah yeah okay
yeah um we were talking was talking
about projects
and i think that could definitely work
in this course i think um
one thing that i've really wanted is to
be able to affect change
in this within the context of this
course and sort of have a reason to do
so
based on the readings um i would like to
go into school and say you know let me
try my hand
and teaching kids in this way and see if
it actually works um
so if you wanted to organize that sort
of thing it could be cool to also work
in small groups
and maybe diversify i mean we have a ton
of different courses in here
but i think there's a lot to be gained
by working going out into the real world
and i think
i mean this is just me great but i think
a three hour course would be
good a good decision okay
so i think just an idea from what colin
said about
talking to someone with a different
ideological perspective than yourself so
maybe like having
students go like groups of two partners
out into the world and like maybe
interview someone or
share some of the information like the
asian revolution happened it was like
one of the most revolutionary
revolutions
okay okay so so going back to dinner
so in terms of going to the schools i
have some good news which is that um i
think i should have articulated you
about this new program that's been
launched in the boston music school the
tournament program
and vivian cam actually she's ethnically
chinese
and she actually she launched chat
launched a jungle program chinese
english in
cambridge she's doing relatively well
for me here and then she's also
responsible for launching this um
uh clear individual english strategy
program
and she's offered that if there are
students in this class and other classes
that i like to
they want to come and volunteer and and
take advantage of that new program in
terms of
doing any research that's especially
this or a directly based or even like to
do with them
measuring students learning gains she'll
be happy to
to work with you but there's one student
in my other class uh
go see it's pastor with uh who's going
together twice
and was going to be going on a weekly
basis to the meetings
to try to understand how they're
creating these new programs
where there'll be i think half half kids
who speak creole and half who don't
speak real and it could be
truly bad angle so you get american or
other epic cities learning centriole and
you get the asian club kids
learning english and bw so i think it's
a it's a really
i think a very radical move for the
customer school they've had all the
programs of that sort
but never one involving a non-impure
language means uh
it's spanish english french english
chinese english but it's the first time
that they're doing one that
um includes a language citation that's
been over
over the years as you know stigmatizing
vague studies so we're
excited getting some pushback including
pushback from
from haitian parents who some of them
would prefer to have in french
as you can imagine right or they don't
speak french but it's a typical
neocolonial you know
into the um language so to speak
but i think that there's been some good
progress in that in fact namshonsky
was here on tuesday he had an interview
which happened on my facebook page
i tried to send it to you where it was
me
uh him and uh and the
assistant superintendent of the little
sister name is
his parents as well from mexico but
she grew up in california and it was a
very interesting exchange between the
two of us
where james was talking about the
importance of promoting these
local languages or really for liberation
of the
spirits of the mind so
i think those are good suggestions it's
a very good suggestion
and since parallel is uh he has his
strong background interpretation
and as you saw during projects involving
virtual reality
that might be another part where we can
do action
just based on what you said like with
fox harold the computation part
um i thought it was really interesting
like learning about what he was doing
but i think if there was like like i
don't know if this is where you're going
but like if i think there was a
if there was more requirement to do more
computation-based things i probably
would have straight away
from this class um because like so i'm
not like the stereotypical major here
like i'm a business major but i think i
would have been like slightly
intimidated if there was like a cms type
project in here
um so maybe like making that one of the
facets of what you can do but not a
requirement okay but
that's good okay yeah yeah yeah good for
you yeah
i think uh also taking advantage of the
learning styles of the students in the
class could be interesting
um so maybe doing more creative projects
or doing projects
that people feel like allow them to use
their
their best skills and actually have fun
i feel like so tell me cynthia so if you
could have them
unfortunately that was creativity what
would you have done
let's get a sense of what you could
think of in the future
just off the fly i maybe would have made
like
a [ __ ] 10 foot tall paper mache
person
written like i don't know stuff
all over it okay put it in lobbying okay
like negative comments or like just like
that but that's interesting
and then and then they would have to
have a part that
includes communication of some sort so
how would you do that so you would do
that and
perhaps have a paper describing what you
did in the mission of what you've done
and your objectives abstract
accomplished
i mean if it was just like a black body
or like a like a brown body of some sort
i would even just leave markers and
stuff for other people to put messaging
on it and be like would be
like giving i think art is a great way
to give people um
an entry into having those conversations
and like great
artifacts excellent excellent in fact
i'm still getting something recorded
this is great so actually anyone has
concrete
suggestions like that so i'll classify
one of those i don't
maybe you have taken a psychology gender
and race
no okay decide by psychologist um
who works uh in the local area all right
first name should be afraid of last name
but um the part of the class is like
training or like doing mock training and
how to present
cultural awareness presentations where
uh
you go with uh you basically from a
group of students
and kind of teach the other students who
are role-playing how to like
uh college fret members of college frat
or like
sixth graders inside of a local boston
public school about like
different um about how some things that
they may be doing
could be disparaging to minority groups
and it could be interesting having a
conversation we're going to see like
what
things she incorporates into those
presentations and if that would be
useful inside of black matters
okay that would be useful to be very
useful
didn't i no i was funny okay
that i think was the new thing this
semester i think and like just another
way
for us to communicate like as students
would be great because
just like maybe someone said something
in class too that was really interesting
and you like only have their email
right like it's like hard to like get in
contact so maybe another like an opt-in
way to have like so the wiki didn't
really work
harder it's not a good platform it's
yeah the wiki is a good platform open
course with you here
the wiki is not good but i heard that as
well in
in my other class the student said we
don't like the wiki
like something that we already all use
and wouldn't have to go out of her way
too
yeah sure uh so you're asking what kind
of projects right
so from like the teaching perspective i
think
after the classes last week i'm learning
about
open and fixed my uh yeah open and fixed
mindset
um something that would have been
interesting as a project
would be to create a curriculum like
just a lecture or a workshop for
an age group whatever age it could be
college it could be
lower and kind of trying to
implement the like teaching techniques
that we learned
to foster a more open uh mindset that
would have been a cool
like project to explore okay okay great
okay so fanny dana
and i wait mine is off of that
okay i think i think it'd be that would
be a good idea and also we could still
enlist the help of the professors who
need these lectures because i think
um that will give us a little more you
know
um when we actually go into these
schools and say no
we'd like to bring this plan to you
because we have
professor backing we have this whole
slew of research behind us
another cool thing that you could do
about like community outreach
is i know one time
a couple weeks ago in amphibious
achievement we had
a bunch of people from chocolate city
come in
and also it's there's a group
it's like something something latinas
and i don't know
yes yeah so they came in and chocolate
city came in
and so you have to give some background
about japanese city uh
induced achievement and oh make it feel
achievement is we it's a program at mit
and we work
uh with boston public high schoolers
and it's like an academic mentorship
program but also we just like work with
them to try to build their confidence
and we also help them
apply to college and things like that
but and then chocolate city is like
just like a it's a living group here on
campus
and it's like african-american men
and then we say it again
that's a
group of like latina women
um and so they came in to talk to the
high schoolers
in amphibious achievement and we just
had like
a discussion about how they feel
about what they've been told they can
and cannot do because of
like who they are and it was really
really interesting
for everybody and i think that would be
something cool
to do like do you have a facebook page
we do
it's called amphibious achievement okay
all right that's what you say definitely
thank you
thank you uh it's actually so good fifth
would be a better way communicating yeah
yeah way better way better so give me an
excuse then we should create a facebook
page for the course
yeah a page for the course and then a
messaging group for the
[Laughter]
good students yeah all right actually
maybe one of you could create a business
page for this for this group
and that's where you guys can keep in
touch and if there are ways that
given what um [ __ ] just explained you
there you should do other other projects
that might bring your
strengths and your knowledge together
it's a big actual change that maybe
something like that but you'd have to be
responsible for it
um bouncing off the irrita i think it'd
be really interesting to like
potentially have one product option be
like
a and mental and masturbatory literacy
like class uh
presentation or something like that
where you like take a certain section of
literature
maybe just one book like madame
wolverine and dissect the ways
in which the society in which it is
embedded
create the themes and within it like a
major thing inside of madame bobre is
like
is centered on this one woman who's like
married in the countryside of france
back in like the 19th or 1800s and she
gets really depressed because she has
nothing to do
and just explaining that like she has no
options for employment
and is stuck at home because that's what
was expected of women back in that day
and like dissecting both that cultural
phenomenon
and then it's like examining how that
may
play out in like today's terms with
different patterns in society
okay so it's 10 55 so we'll give you
the last period wow okay
um so something that i was thinking
about was
what you had said and about having like
that art project
um and i realized i'm not artistic at
all so i was trying to figure out what i
would do if there was an art assignment
and i was thinking about something that
didn't show
where like you put yourself up like you
stand up there and then you have like a
projector screen
and you write words on it of what you
don't like about yourself and that could
be like instead of like what we don't
like about ourselves like things we've
been told
about ourselves based off our race or
based on our gender or sexuality then
also having things you would rather have
been said
um because i i really liked about this
class was the self-exploration
so good all right so thank you so much
and